hello everyone and welcome to the final
recapture of the saint louis rapid and
blitz my name is tatif abrahamian and
i'm going to take you to the key moments
of the final day
so today nine mo splits games were
played and the tournament winner was
declared so if you don't know who that
is yet i am not going to do any spoilers
i'm actually going to go
round by round and go through key
moments uh there's
there have been 45 games that were
played today so there's again no way we
can really look through all of them
or give them enough attention so i'm
just going to go through the key ones
and give you
a round by round play of what happened
in the tournament today
so since we have a lot of games to go
through let's get started
so as i mentioned yesterday it was a two
horse race between
magnus carlson and wesley and as i
mentioned yesterday it was very very
unlikely that
there was going to be a big upset and
someone else was gonna finish in top two
and
um yeah realistically that wasn't gonna
happen because there was such a huge gap
so it was a two horse race uh between
those two
uh so in the first game we had hikaru
nakamura versus magnus carlsen
uh so there's uh something funny
happened magnus showed up to the
game uh kind of late so you can actually
see this on the
official broadcast when he's putting on
his shirt like he checks on the
videos like all my game has started and
he's still like getting dressed
uh so he's playing with the black pieces
so i can actually look at the whole game
because this game ended
very quickly
so we have um sicilian
and we're going to see that things go
wrong for the world champion
quite quickly so all of this is pretty
standard
trade of the bishops um big fight over
the d5 square
so this 97 a very suspicious move that's
going
for um some kind of a smashing of like
position and really banking on the fact
that he can
play not there
d5 very quickly after um
knight f6 so king runs away from many
kinds of checks
and rook d3 not hiding his um intentions
of
bringing the rock bringing the queen and
checkmatic
uh side of desperation takes and now
queen h4 is played and of course it
cannot take
because uh we can take on f6
actually or we can play rook h3 simply
ending the game
so this would be very unfortunate
instead he won knight g8
and after this move he simply resigned
because queen g4 is coming with
unstoppable checkmate and if the knight
moves
the rook slides back to h3 so really
shocking way for the world champion to
lose but it kind of seemed like he
wasn't
really into this game and he just kind
of rushed through it
uh very one-sided game as you can see he
has 42 seconds left and he car will
spend like
a minute and a half and
this was a very unpleasant start for him
and wesley saw drew his um
his game against his countryman jeffrey
junk and now the two players are tight
but
and so there's another player who had a
very good result today and that player
is levon aronian
so he won some um he wants a lot of good
games so we'll also take a look at his
games
and um also uh alexander grishof and
yandy bom
there is also remember a big time big
race for the third place it was between
hikaru nepo and chris chook so in the
first round grisha and nepo
play each other the first round of the
day rather so this is around 10 of blitz
so if you look at the position you see
this crazy pump formation
so we're going to see how grease chuck
is just
um going to destroy his opponent so the
pawn reaches there so almost like
rook d7 become more difficult to play
and just ending the game in a really
super one-sided
manner so this was a great result for
griez chook
knocking out um yanni ponchi and his
race for third place
and our other decisive results of round
10 was
furious versus lemonaran which is such a
heartbreaking way for furuja to lose
in the very last moment he just um
plundered his knight
and the problem is you cannot queen here
because um we just
cannot stop this pawn because stop being
this way
and if for k1 we've already talked about
this end game many many times
two pawns another rank i mean we've seen
so many examples of this during this
tournament it's just unstoppable
all right so uh let's move on to our
next round so next round we have magnus
carlson against yandy bomnichi
in a key game uh so this game was pretty
crazy game
and there's a key moment that i wanted
to show you
and it is this so
a lot of things happen in this game and
again i cannot really do justice to any
of these games in this kind of a
format because it's 45 games and we're
doing a recap
so we land in this position and here um
magnus rushes by taking this pump
what he needs to do is he needs to slide
back and
defend this f4 pawn so he can have two
pass punt
instead he takes and now he loses his f4
pawn and the problem is this pass bond
is so
advanced and the king is so close that
the knight can come and sacrifice itself
for the pawn
so something like this was played
and there's just no way to make progress
so they just repeat it
and the game ended in a draw so there's
also no
doing this because we're just gonna
queen at the same time and i'm gonna
queen with a check
and i'm gonna force a trade of queens
actually
we're gonna trade queens and i will win
the game so this would be a really
unfortunate way of ending the game
uh and wesley saw himself through his
game against icarus i'm going to show
you
what happened and i'm going to ask you
to remember this you might have seen
this between carlson and nakamura in
their um
that epic match that they had for a
magnus invitational
this position and the straw
so you probably seen this before but do
remember this because
we are going to see this position today
later at some point so
remember this game remember this
position we're going to come back to it
so again magnus drew wesley drew um
so around two of the day around 11
pleats overall
the two are still tied for first place
and let's take a look
at a game by level naronian who won his
second uh consecutive game
this time against alexander christchuck
uh so let's jump
to move 58.
and i just wanted to show you the
dominance of
the bishop versus a knight so here he is
up upon but still you know this kind of
positions are
really easy to messed up to mess up and
one thing we want to look at is this
corner pawn and you know you have the
correct bishop so that's a big
big deal the bishop before is played
king devon
so the knight cannot check you so the
pawn reaches all the way seven rank
so it's basically trying to keep his
king
here so you cannot take my d3 pawn but
he uses his pawn to
distract the king and now the knight is
trapped and again
we've seen another example it was wesley
so again plebonaroni and when the bishop
dropped the knight remember there was um
i believe a knight was on h5 when a
bishop wants one e5 oops
sorry knight was on h5 when a bishop was
on e5
and uh he chopped i believe that was the
format and he
chopped this uh knight maybe it was a
bishop on e3 in the night on h3
the knight got trapped so this kind of
situation we have
and the knight two squares in between
and the bishop the bishop just drops the
knight basically when the knights on the
edge
so reach this position and then i just
getting super wanked and the knight is
getting trapped
so really nice win by levan aronia two
in a row for a day
all right and now let's move on to the
next round round 12
we are going to have a key match-up in
this round
magnus carls and wesley so which could
be really decisive for the standings
so magnus carlsen with the white pieces
did defeat wesley saw so let's take a
more
look at the key moment where he plays g6
which is such an annoying move to face
because he cannot take the knight to
spawn wool queen
so instead he goes h5 knight d7
takes the pawn
and these two pawns are kind of rolling
so he gave up his bishop out of
desperation but unfortunately we're
going to see
how easily the world champion wins this
and by easily i mean he makes it look
easy
so choose the king away
and starts bringing his own king
stopping all the checks now the knight
joins the game
and just playing so well
and now the pawn is falling
fix the pawn
and you're going to crawl the pawn
knight g2 and actually he just runs into
checkmate
so um just a very um when you look at
this game
it just seems so easy and like black
white never had to
think about it you know like every move
is so natural and every move is so good
so
this techniques which is flawless by the
world champion so this gave him
a point lead with one third of the
tournament of
the day done so there's six more rounds
to go
and one more game we want to look at is
between dominguez and the gamora
let's go to that game and let's jump to
move
55 so this is a very complicated game
and i checked it with the engine and
it's not very clear to understand what
the engine is trying to do
so he played bishop b6 which hangs upon
with a tempo and what he has to do is
play bishop d2 and the point is to
defend this pawn
try to trap the bishop and then bring
the king around
excuse me and then i think the whole
point is that this knight really cannot
move because this pawn is hanging
so these bishops are really annoying and
there's really no way for black to
utilize this
past punk instead bishop b6 was played
so he wins a pawn and he just starts to
collect
every single pawn
so this pawn is falling this pawn is
um very close to queening
and by close moving the next move
because a2 and
unfortunately there is no way of
stopping this pawn so
again really nice win by nakamura his
opponent makes one mistake
and everything was just one-sided one
mistake and just basically the game was
over
so now going um one third we're done
with the date so let's move on to the
next round and keep in mind that
um magnus carlsen is a full point ahead
of his opponent
okay so let's move on to round 13 so
magnus carlsen drew his game against the
level narunian but uh wesley so had a
great result so narrowing the gap so in
this position
queen c3 is played defends the pawn and
now he goes
h4 sacrificing the pawn and going for
this structure and this looks really
really dangerous
but the problem is with this bishop if i
ever play king f1
it's going to be really difficult to
really checkmate me because my king just
runs
so repeats once queen c5
and simply takes the pawn and this is
just game over because
check and just falling apart the whole
position but here the position was
already really bad because the five
pound is hanging
and unclear how to defend this pawn
uh so narrowing the gap now we're
four games in and now magnus carlson is
only half a point ahead of
wesley so so there's another game i
wanted to show it's between uh
firuja and nakamura i know this uh
they're fan favorites
uh so this is the final position let me
jump back to
the position where i which where i
wanted to start the reason i want to
show you is because this is so
entertaining
so black has eight pawns and white has a
night
and five months uh so material wise it's
equal
i'm sorry black has seven pawns and uh
white has five pounds in a knight so
material wise white is doing
better but like this position is just
insane
and i think one issue that already had
in this tournament
is his time management
so this was played
brings the king defends the pawns
gives up the pawn and brings the rook
around so i think hikaru just played on
his time
so and he declines a repetition which
you know you have to respect because
you would think in this position you're
like okay i'm down a piece let me just
go for a draw but he just goes for it
and just declines our repetition here
too
and it's so easy here to make a mistake
because if we
visualize his position something like
the three and you're getting made it
and very scary to play against these
pawns
so let's take a look at how this game
transpired
so it goes there so he gives up this
knight but unfortunately after check
uh there's just going to be no way to
stop the pawn because if you block
and um the pawn is queening and
the game is just over so i thought this
was a really entertaining game between
the two fan favorites all the reserves
and hikaru nakamura and that fun for
pound formation was something very
unusual and
probably something we well i haven't
seen very often and i'm sure you haven't
either
all right so now we're almost halfway
done with the tournament
so let's move on to round 14 which is
the fifth round of the day
and in this round both carlson and so
drew their game so there was no changes
in the standings for them they're still
how um
magnus crossing is still half a point
ahead of wesley so and i just
wanted to show you one moment um from
this game between dominguez and
uh carlson because uh dominguez plays
knight d5 and now this move looks
very natural and i just wanted to show
you this possible tactic but of course
they didn't happen
but bishop b6 and
this checkmate in the back rank
so this didn't happen bishop b6 wasn't
played
instead he played h6 which is such a
scary looking move
and we're going to see a perpetual
rather three-fold repetition that our
perpetual
and all of this is forced so just h6 was
an opportunity for dominguez to make a
draw and he is a few pawns down so you
know
um not uh not a bad idea to make a drop
and instead k8 was the right move but i
think this is a very difficult move to
play to put your king
on h8 when you already have back rank
issues so i think h6 may be more it was
more of a natural choice
but it did force a drum and
we also had another uh exciting round uh
game in this round it was again
um nepo and junk and we've seen apple
uh win some really nice game and lose
some very
one-sided game so i just wanted to show
what happened in this game and this
would be the second time that jeffrey
zhang defeats
yanni ponich in this tournament so this
is called the bishop's opening
so all of this has been played before so
everything looks normal and it's hard to
believe this game is going to end in
like 10 moves
because looks like a normalish looking
position
and rook after maybe was a bit much
and um we see that's one unhappy queen
and the problem is you do not have
something like rook f7 which you would
like to play
it's because of the pin so this was
played
because if queen c6 then rook f7 and
left rook is hanging
science there gate was played he takes
i have to show you guys all the nice
tactics in the position
losing everything so takes here and now
the bishop is just falling because again
of this pin
uh you know so very costly move that
queen b7 looks like you're just grabbing
pawn and instead the queen just got
trapped
so now we only have four more games to
go
so let's move on to the next game let's
move on to round 15.
uh so let's take a look at the game
between magnus carlson and pentala hare
krishna this was a
very crazy french game and let's jump
right into this position where
magnus plays h5
and hari krishna sacrifices a piece but
that's just the beginning
and now he sacrifices a full rook so the
compensation is
if we count one two three four four
white one two
three four five six seven so
three pounds and a pair of bishops
so the position is still quite complex
the engine says white is doing really
well but i think over the board it's
really hard to
know for sure maybe magnus magnus does
because you know his magnus but i think
anyone else especially lower the lower
you go in the rating i think the scarier
white's positions feels
so bishop c6 now we're going to see how
magnus just shows good technique again
and again he makes it seem so easy so he
grabs the pawn
comes back for the c3 pawn and now that
he's grabbed enough pants he's ready to
give up his piece
and going after the bishop so this
position is already
quite easy because um this kind of
formation you can never do anything to
my king and this pawn is forever
defended so now the rook is coming in
grabs a pawn and really nice mating net
but here it didn't matter where the king
went because in this position
we have knight f4 but we can also take
on e6
i think maybe not f4 is even better so i
thought this was a really nice game by
magnus
uh accepting the sacrifice and you know
playing so fearlessly and
maneuvering that position um handling
that position so what i'm just
winning again his wins just look so easy
get a complicated
complicated position and then all of a
sudden it's a win
and um there's another uh game i wanted
to show
it was between lanier and ferozia
so let's jump to move 42
this position we've seen so many end
games you guys should be experts by now
so the rook slides away and i wanted to
show you how to win this end game
so they're actually they're going to b5
was very awkward because
just gets in the way of the pawn and
furious win
is very simple here and i really really
like the smooth rook e5 multi-purpose
move
monday threatening rook t5 cutting this
guy off
and you're threatening this pawn as well
and again i can so for example so we
can't take on d5
but something like this these are not
the best move
but we already saw an example right like
this right queening
and checking and trading queens of
course we don't have to do this we can
just take the pawn on b5
so which is why i like this rook uh if i
move because you're both
um you know like kind of like a lucina
position but at the same time attacking
upon search x rook c5
d2 and the next move if rook t8
i will take the pawn and then i will
play rook d5 so
you lose the pawn and you let me queen
so very very painful
um things are happening to white in this
position
so linear dominguez actually resigned
after d2
so i thought uh you know we've seen a
lot of instructive end games so we
should uh continue the trend
uh so because uh wesley so drew his game
against alexander krischuk
i actually will show you this game so
because this is all theory
so this has been played before i i
believe this was played by um fabiano
against mama jarav
if i'm not mistaken uh so again i cannot
really offer a lot of
uh commentary because this is all theory
and you know we're not having a
theoretical discussion here
so 95 so all of this has been worked out
so those of you who are amateurs
i know this makes chess a little bit
overwhelming but you know at the higher
level
of chess has a lot of openings have been
worked out
so knight f3
and here there is this amazing rook c4
move which um
i feel like it's kind of an unnatural
move
and we have to try to understand what
the point of this move
is for example if we take
and it looks like the queen is kind of
getting trapped here because
you don't have this move i can't go here
but i think it's like all these lines
are so computerized like
i i just don't see how this is so
natural that someone would just find it
so easily and just play
for example if this queen goes here i
don't know maybe the queen is just
getting trapped
or maybe just the position is so good
and the actually the more we look at it
you know the more we see how good the
tag is here but
i'm not sure how easy it is to find a
move like rook c4 so i guess we can
in a way call this an escape for um
wesley saw because he if rook c4 was
played he would be in a
very bad shape and the game ended in a
draw
so now there are three more rounds to go
and magnus carlsen has a
full point lead and this is the kind of
thing that you know usually makes him
very comfortable
that he is going to win the tournament
but still three games to go still a lot
of chess to be played
so let's move on to the next round let's
jump to our game between
yandy pandey and wesley and this game
was quite wild actually and in this
position
wesley plays a3 and then the post game
interview he admits that he offered a
try and his opponent declined and he
said i wanted to thank him for declining
this drop because
well you can see the result and bishop
g4
so this is a great game so let's just
take a look
and we see by sacrificing a piece this
pawn is going to fall
and we see how great the a3 move is
because
the possibilities because the knight
landing on c3 so this is like
i feel like such a high class move
so he gives up this pawn and takes this
with a tempo
and here um
i think nepal realized um not a lot of
good moves in this position because if
you play rook g1
and impossible to defend this knight
this square is covered this square is
covered
okay so instead he plays bishop c4
and uh here he actually got disconnected
and lost the game even but his position
is already busted he's down material
uh the problem with uh for him is this
king is just permanently weak
so for example if we do something like
this
and you take
uh so the problem is you cannot go to
the corner so here first
i can at some point grab this pawn and
probably queen
but i also have something like this
winning the rook
then i will take the pawn on a2 and the
pawn will queen so this will be very
unfortunate
uh so it's kind of funny that um
nipponichi in a way influenced this
tournament so much because
magnus disconnected against him and of
course it's not his fault that magnus
hack
happened to disconnect against him and
last to
him to disconnection and napolita
last um by this connection to magnus's
rival
so you know that's a lot of points
against one person
for the same reason so that part is kind
of funny
so magnus drew his game so now the lead
is
narrowing down to half a point
and there was another game i wanted to
show that was between hari krishna and
jeffrey zhang
and let's jump to move 50
and this game i just wanted to show you
guys how
to escape from this kind of checks and
again they're playing with no time and
it's just amazing how they manage
because here i think if i was playing i
could lose this position for both colors
well
uh one of the colors did lose but i just
feel like um
not being able to escape from the checks
and plunder your bishop or something is
just so easy to do to fall into some
kind of a
perpetual so the screen c3 was actually
not the correct move but let's see how
he just runs away from these checks
so making a few moves repeating a few
moves and
um gaining some time on the clock this
guy is hanging but now bishop blocks
and now we're going to see how he's
going to utilize his bishop
and very important we're out of checks
now the pawn just marches and
importantly we're plugging the diagonal
and this diagonal and this diagonal so
the king is just safe
so h4 a little desperate
but you know it's blitz it's online why
not and the game is over so i thought
just amazing play by penta
hari krishna all right so we have two
more rounds to go
and wesley is so it's still behind
magnus carlsen
so you know there's still uh the
tournament can go either way so either
player can
win or there can be a tie and just to
remind everyone if you guys didn't know
in case of a tag
uh the official rules say there will be
no um
being a play-up so there's still three
possibilities that magnus wins that
wesley wins or there is a tie
all right let's take a look at our
penultimate round so in this round
uh so you see magnus carlsen won this
game and so did wesley so
so again natalie changes uh no changes
in the standings
for the first two going into the final
round so let's take a look at how magnus
carlsen defeated jeffrey zhang
so d4 very nice move a pawn break
and now the knight comes in
takes this guy takes this guy and not
how he didn't grab the exchange here
and instead he's just taking the punt
because now these pawns are just going
to be unstoppable
there was a temple move
okay and here he blundered but these
pawns are just
going to be unstoppable and also rookie
it was a threat trying to win a piece
so not much he could have done here
anyways
knight d5 was also a threat and you
cannot really escape from all of it it's
just too many threats
so he went here stopping 95. he run into
it this is just one of those positions
where there's so many threats you know
you
can only stop like one or two but
something else will pop up
it's a pretty tough loss for the young
player with the white pieces
and uh giving magnus a pretty
comfortable lead but you know wesley saw
had a very
strong
streak so he wins another another uh
game in a row this time against levon
aronian so let's go to this position and
this is a pretty complicated position
so we see black is attacking but white
does have this really nice
defensive piece so king goes to g2 plays
f4
and then it's funny enough there's just
no way
nowhere to go
it's a knight g3 and i really like this
in between move
so it takes the king really nice so
eater is defended
and now the rest is going to be a matter
of technique
so threatening meat and just grabbing
all the puns
and um i wanted to show you the end
of the game because bishop b6 feel like
you're winning a piece but
rugby five and this is just game over
and he just goes for this side of the
board
bishop b5 you're gonna take on g7 and
this pawn is just gonna march down the
board
so pretty comfortable win for uh wesley
saw so now
we're going into the last round and
let's carlson still have a point ahead
so still anything can happen in this
tournament
all three um finishes are possible
magnus winning vastly winning or a tie
so
you know this is what commentators and
the fans like that everything gets
decided in the final round
so before i show you anything else in
the final round i want to show you
this so maybe you've seen this
and hikar decides to play kingi
and you see the result what happened so
of course this is i'm sure um
something that did not feel very good
for jeffrey and if you go and watch the
official broadcast if you go towards the
end
through magnus carlson interview he
actually talks about his opening and he
shows other opening where he give up
bunch of pawns and then i think he said
that in this position he would play
he would play king seven king e1
king and you play like no castle chess
so you
so this was his suggestion well he said
this is what he would have done
and he had a pretty fun interview
talking about this and like you know
talking about all kinds of
um crazy
variants or something in the out of the
opening so this is really entertaining
so you guys should definitely check that
out
so this is something i wanted to show
you that had nothing to do with our
final standings for our top
plays so let's find out what happened
and who won this tournament ultimately
and uh the game between alexander
grieschick and magnus carlson so
remember that
other game i showed you and i told you
guys remember that position and
here we are it's the exact same position
exact same opening
so alexander grisha goes for this line
after magnus cross and chose the
berlin so not much to do
for magnus carlsen so he settles for a
draw and now
it is completely up to wesley saw so
unless the sword is in a must-win
position with the black pieces against
pentaho krishna
so once i click on this you guys are
going to find out what happened so
there you go so wesley didn't win
his game that he managed he managed to
win with the black pieces very clutch
victory
uh really amazing result for him tying
for first with
magnus carlsen so let's take a look at
this game
so in this position pentel aggravation
goes e5 taking advantage of the fight
this knight is low so you cannot take
but then queen g5 is in the air
sometimes tactics don't work out
and he grabs a pawn and another one
and now the position with the two
bishops just completely falls apart
so knight goes to e7
and he's just up way too many pawns and
um
there's a funny moment here when he
plays rook to knight g6 and then you see
where's his reaction list is like what
is this move
he's seven but he just ignores it and
with the two bishops this
two extra pawns there's just nothing to
do
and now we see in addition to everything
there is also
a problematic ink
this doesn't quite work out because of
the check
repeat once
and we see in the game that probably out
of desperation he did it anyways because
bishop b7 was coming
and the position was just going to be
really horrible and
resigns anyways so congratulations to
both of the players
to magnus carlos and leslie so they tied
for first place they finished um
with a really impressive result and took
home forty five thousand dollars for uh
five days of play which is
um pretty nice uh pretty nice price fund
so this has been a really great event so
thank you guys for checking it out
so the next big event or series of big
events for you san luis is going to be
the us championships
so it's going to be five championships
u.s juniors us2 news girls u.s seniors
years women's where i'll be playing
and the us championship so you make sure
you guys are checking it out on usgs
champs and on san luis's youtube channel
thanks for watching and see you guys
later